la droite et de retour
et elle est vraiment debout les
programmes qui ont été choisis par les
adhérents sont des programmes de droites
assumé pour porter ce projet des
républicains une yvelinoise Valérie
Pécresse est engagée politiquement
depuis de nombreuses années dans le
département député de la deuxième
circonscription de 2002 à 2007 puis de
2012 à 2016 la Présidente de la Région
Île-de-France est aujourd'hui élue dans
la commune de Vélizy-Villacoublay un
ancrage mis en avant par les élus locaux
dont Pierre Bédié président du conseil
départemental des Yvelines bravo à
Valérie Pécresse pour sa belle et
incontestable victoire département le
mieux géré de France les Yvelines
proposent aux Français une yvelinoise
rassemblement pour Valérie c'est tout
son côté Shirak en fait elle aime aller
au contact et si elle est aujourd'hui
conscient municipale à Vélizy c'est
aussi parce qu'elle avait envie de se
confronter et d'être en phase avec la
réalité du terrain et c'est vrai que
c'est à ce moment là où on peut se faire
chuter on peut être challenger deuxième
à l'issue du premier tour du Congrès
Valérie Pécresse la finalement emporté
face à Éric Ciotti avec 60,95 % des voix
plus de 82 % des 140 000 adhérents du
parti ont participé au scrutin si elle a
gagné c'est parce que elle avait le
meilleur projet le plus précis
le plus chiffré c'est à la fois son
projet qui est le projet d'une droite
assumée comme elle le dit assez ferme
sur toutes les questions réelles et en
même temps ouverte sur les questions qui
sont des questions parfois peu
appréhender par la droite je pense
notamment à tous les sujets
environnementaux le sujet de famille et
puis c'est le choix aussi d'une
personnalité dont on a reconnu la
capacité à fédérer désormais de l'unité
dans le parti de droite ericsiotti a
estimé dimanche 4 décembre que Valérie
Pécresse n'avait pas envoyé un message
de rassemblement lors de son premier
discours de candidate sur Twitter le
député des Alpes-Maritimes a ensuite
affirmé vouloir porter ses idées en duo
avec elle lors de la campagne
présidentielle l'unité tiendra-t-elle le
coup jusqu'à la présidentielle avec Éric
Zemmour qui a déjà fait un appelle Lupi
aux électeurs d'Eric Ciotti pas
d'inquiétude chez les républicains la
barrière herbétique avec les droits
tradicales c'est une réalité qui n'a pas
commencé hier c'était vrai du temps du
RPR avec Jacques Chirac c'est vrai
aujourd'hui aux républicains et je suis
certain que Éric Ciotti il sera fidèle
sa famille politique ce matin Valérie
Pécresse a fait son premier déplacement
chez eriki elle ira chez Xavier Bertrand
vendredi il faut bien se rappeler
quelque chose c'est qu'on a tous envie
de gagner en avril prochain en 2017
c'est François Fillon qui avait porté la
candidature LR empêtré dans plusieurs
affaires judiciaires il s'était classé
troisième du premier tour avec 20% des
suffrages derrière Emmanuel Macron et
Marine Le Pen